Hãy mươi sau tháng bẩy, khô nghĩ suピến đầu từ lâu cây.
Năm 2 nhìn không trong 2 mươi sau đã chính thức khai mạng với chủ ý hỏa độ kết nủ xanh nghiệp và khoảng 3 tiêm năng địa phương.
Mình cạnh các dễn đả đối thoại nhằm thảo gửi điểm ngễn, hiện tự quả một tiêu xanh nghiệp phát tài,
lâu cây phát triển khu trưng bây sản phẩm địa phương cho thành địa hệ suy động của hàng chục thập tác sán,
khuột sản xuất và zanh nghiệp.
Sự kiện đã tù hút được đung đảo nguy raen, su khách đến thăm quan, mua sản thân đặc sản của địa phương.
Tên bây giờ xí xuất hiện thông hại tình hấu gây, là hai không phải sấu thì bê mình rất vinh dự ki được thăm ra khách trưng trình.
Hồi trọng vào, tên mám lĩa gá sản phẩm từ hòa quát, mất tả mẹn, ô mài tả mẹn,
mẹn sế chào, giấm tả mẹn và dự tả mẹn và điều là sản thình ủ khúc bà xa.
Tư tả mẹn, là ủi, quát, bười đến các vải hảo, đủ đặc sản,
mối sản phẩm đường mang theo cù chuyển về bung đất, con người và hành trình dự giả trị đông nghiệp bản điệp.
Không chỉ là hằng hoa, đây còn là sinh kế của hàng nghìn hộ dân mình nguy,
đang tự bước đung cao giả trị đông sản thông qua chế biến và sây dự tương yếu.
Mà tổ là mình biết tả trồng rất sạp bấm, bấm tự ý hữu tơ.
Đi đẹp mẹn là sĩ khá hô cho bà con và mẹn tập viet ta kê sà lừng lựu, mấy quế, dự tả trị đông.
Cô bà con, gây dự tích chồng, khá nàn lựng rồi, bà bế tổ cư tụt của bà con để tăng cúc tình đồ gà tư tụt.
Chào bà con, lấy nó hôm nay đến bởi hộ lỡ liệu ý a xúc tiến em này.
Em bởi tôn tế của mô ra nó tất sản, mong muốn, đẹp mà những cái sản phẩm đung sản của địa phương mình.
Để dối thiệu đến, nó khắp nhống chiếm chồng nước mà có thể kết lối được với nước ngoài để tụt.
Sao tổn đung sản cho bà con, chỉ chỉ khu hôm mẹ.
Điểm nhấn của sự kiện là hô gực mê gà lài.
Thế vì chỉ trở khách gái sân hàng, các chủ thể ô cốt lần đầu được hỗ trợ lai stream trên nghiệp.
Để đưa đặc sản lâu cai tiếp cận người tư dùng trên nền tăng số.
Trong sát mong dự gửa của trong phục dân tộc, những câu chuyện về sản phẩm được kể chực tiếp qua tình phyên mê gà lài.
Bông nghị số kết hợp cùng bà xác phần ngoài đã bởi giá cách làm lối cho xúc tiến thương mại.
Zúc nhiều dân hàng giết nhận đường khác tăng mạnh và liên tục phát sinh đường hàng ngay trong ngày đủ tiến.
Mình cũng cảm thấy thật là máy mắn khi mà thăm ra kể hơi gị xúc đêm thương mại tình lâu cai.
Lắm này thì mình đừng mọi người uống mộ rất là nhiều và mọi người đã dành được những cái phản hồi rất thích cực.
Ừ mình còn những cái thàn phòng trong người ăn thử tại gán hàng thì mọi người thương ăn thử và mọi người khách nôn sau đó thì là mọi người đã mua uống hộ mình rất là nhiều.
Saáng ngày mùi bày tháng bày, hồi nghị số thiến đầu tư lào cai năm 2019, kết tục mỗi nhiều hạt động kết mối và kết kết hợp tác.
Tuy nhiên, giễn thản đối thoại đến các phía người gà ngài xù đồng.
Lâu cai đang tưởng bu vức tạo nên hệ sinh thái số thiến đầu tư và thương mại hiện đại.
Nơi giá chỉ vàng quá bản địa được kết nổ người con nghệ số để vinh tơi những thị trường dọng lơn hơn.